comenzaron los funerales para despedir a
las decenas de personas que murieron el
jueves tras el ataque del estado
islámico en afganistán cerca del
aeropuerto de kabul pero no todos han
podido hacer el ritual decenas de
cadáveres estaban en el suelo a las
afueras del hospital wazir akbar khan de
la capital la morgue del centro clínico
no da abasto y muchos familiares apenas
están viajando desde provincias lejanas
otros no pudieron recuperar los cuerpos
a tiempo a pesar de estar en kabul
no había nadie para sacar a los heridos
y a los cadáveres del agua y la mayoría
de las personas murieron porque los
extranjeros bloquearon la carretera
durante una hora después del ataque
algunos murieron porque las carreteras
estaban bloqueadas hasta que me han
grabado aunque el pentã gono advierte
que las amenazas siguen activas cientos
de afganos siguieron dirigiéndose a la
terminal el grupo talibán tomó el
control en la zona y bloqueó el acceso
al puente aéreo
vivimos aquí porque teníamos un vuelo
pero han bloqueado las carreteras y no
permiten a nadie entrar al aeropuerto ni
siquiera a quienes han trabajado en
instituciones extranjeras ni a los
periodistas ni a quienes corren peligro
así que la gente está en una situación
muy difícil
al menos 5000 afganos siguen dentro del
aeropuerto esperando que los saquen del
país antes de que las tropas extranjeras
se terminan de retirar el 31 de agosto y
a pesar de que el talibán intenta calmar
los ánimos diciendo que luego podrán
salir en vuelos comerciales todavía no
es claro qué aerolíneas regresarían a un
aeropuerto controlado por los militantes
fundamentalistas el grupo le pidió a
turquía que opere el aeropuerto pero el
presidente reyerta y perdón respondió
que tomara una decisión sólo después de
que la nueva administración afgana sea
clara